nato leaders have said that the rising
influence of china has become
a systematic systematic challenge to the
global order
china's mission to the european union
has pushed back accusing nato of
exaggerating the threat from
china now nato's statement follows talks
on monday in brussels
it is the first summit for u.s president
joe biden
who has urged a tougher line on china
and
russia while seeking to repair relations
with allies at the meeting
it was joe biden's first nato summit
you may keep your masks off now please
turn and watch the digital tower
and the us president arrived in brussels
with a promise
to reaffirm the united states commitment
to a military alliance his predecessor
viewed with disdain
then it was down to business identifying
old
and new threats to the alliance russia
and china
are both seeking to drive a wedge in our
transatlantic solidarity
we're seeing an increase in malicious
cyber activity
it's the first time the alliance has
branded china a security threat
but leaders also stress that nato is
seeking to work with beijing
when it comes to global issues such as
climate change
an approach german chancellor angela
merkel strongly supports
when looking at cyber threats hybrid
threats
the cooperation between russia and china
i believe
you just can't ignore china we shouldn't
overstay this in my view so we have to
find the right balance
looming large at the summit was also the
scramble to complete
nato's withdrawal from afghanistan after
the united states surprised partners by
ordering u.s
troops home after almost 20 years
nato military operations are coming to
an end
we pay tribute to all those who have
lost their lives
or been wounded please put your masks on
joe biden will meet top eu officials
this tuesday
before his much anticipated meeting with
russian president vladimir putin later
this week
and putting it all into context for us
barbara basil is standing by in brussels
barbara
nato also taking a tough line on china
as we've heard at yesterday's summit
what does this mean for tensions
it means that tensions are really going
to increase because
clearly joe biden said 10 years ago
when nato did their last big strategic
review
china wasn't even mentioned and russia
was a partner
and now the allies are looking around
and they find the international scenario
just scary and that is what's really was
reflected yesterday in those discussions
of course there are warning voices like
we heard from angela merkel and some
other europeans saying
we need to work with them i mean we're
talking about exports and imports
we're talking about the economies that
are rather sort of intertwined already
but on the other hand the military
buildup
in the south china sea for instance is
something that
sort of threatens the nato partners and
that
sort of pushes them in really changing
their outlook
on on the strategy for the next 10 years
meantime barbara we know that biden is
now moving on to meet eu leaders today
he will of course see some familiar
faces
trade will take center stage there
what's on the agenda now going forward
yeah after the love feast that was the
g7 and almost
also in in a way nato yesterday we're
coming down to the nitty-gritty today
with the eu because this is about
the real economic world what's at stake
is probably uh that we're going to have
news later this day
about a new agreement on a termination
of the longest running trade battle of
the wto
the battle between boeing and airbus
about state
subsidies there is a plan on the table
and we hear
that the the talks are almost at the
finishing line about having a several
year long sort of cap to these subsidies
that then will have to be paid equally
it could only be paid equally on both
sides
now a lot of terrorists have been rising
out of this battle
and the french vineyards for instance
people who grow wine in france they're
going to heave a sigh of relief
if those tariffs will be lifted and this
agreement can be
made today barbara basil in brussels
thank you